[Musik]
mein heutiger gast im dialog ist oskar
lafontaine eigentlich braucht man sie
nicht vorzustellen
trotzdem was so schön ist als
kanzlerkandidat der spd
parteivorsitzender der spd dann gründer
der linken und parteivorsitzender der
linken
herzlich willkommen bei phoenix was
empfinden sie denn beim gegenwärtigen
zustand der spd
trauer denn einmal fühle ich mich der
spd natürlich lebenslänglich verbunden
zum anderen muss sich das politisch
bewerten wenn die spd immer schwächer
wird werden die möglichkeiten sozialer
gerechtigkeit durchzusetzen immer
geringer also trauer und auch politisch
enttäuschung dass die spd aus den fehler
nicht lernen sie muss ja auch keinen
kommentator hören auf keinen früheren
parteivorsitzenden
aber sie sollte auf die wählerinnen und
wähler hören nur das ist das
erstaunliche obwohl die spd immer wieder
wahlen verliert ändert ihre politik
nicht jetzt werden natürlich viele
spd-mitglieder sagen der oskar
lafontaine soll bloß ruhig sein
der hat auch den niedergang der spd erst
ausgelöst das sehe ich natürlich ganz
anders ich antworte dann kurz ich bin
aus der partei ausgetreten aber im
programm geblieben ihr seid aus dem
programm ausgetreten und in der partei
geblieben das ist meine antworten das
ist ja auch des pudels kern mit einem
programm wie wir sie etwa wie wir es
noch 98 vertreten haben würde die spd
heute in jedem fall deutlich über 30
prozent zustimmung haben
überlegen sie auch manchmal wenn ich
nicht raus gegangen wäre weiter gekämpft
hätte für meine position fest an heute
vielleicht ganz anders aus es ist ja
verständlich überlege ich das manchmal
das ist ja klar ich will ja gelogen das
nicht zuzugeben was wäre besser gewesen
nun habe ich mich so entschieden
bis zum heutigen da hat die spd ja nicht
verstanden was die kandidatur 2005
bedeutet hat sie hat bedeutet dass es
nach der wahl eine deutliche linke
mehrheit noch gab in anführung uns war
gelang es uns ja damals wähler
stimmen zu werben zu werben die von der
spd überhaupt nicht mehr erreichbar
waren
aber die spd war nicht bereit diese
deutliche mehrheit zu nutzen
jetzt verstehe ich ja oder ihre ihre
kritik an der spd die geht ja im
wesentlichen immer in diese richtung zu
sehr neoliberale agenda politik und
dagegen sitzen sie ihre alternativen mit
allerdings partei nur wenn sie recht
haben mit ihrem kurs wieso ist die linke
dann nicht stärker also eine 9 prozent
partei so viel hatten sie bei der
letzten bundestagswahl ist ja keine
alternative zur volkspartei spd
das ist richtig und zunächst einmal dass
es möglich ist mit einem so klaren
linken programm viel mehr wählerinnen
und wähler für sich zu gewinnen sagt
calvin in england das ist der beweis
dass das funktioniert oder dein einwand
müssen sind wir gestatten okay kommt ist
eindrucksvoll
aber das was corbijn wirklich erreicht
hat war eine knappe niederlage gegen die
konservativen gewonnen hat auch der noch
nicht das ist richtig aber er hat eben
ein labour party aufgerichteten
ähnlichem zustand war wie die spd
wir haben zum beispiel ein problem das
ich von anfang an gesehen hatte wir
werden immer noch assoziiert mit der
ehemaligen pds und damit eben auch mit
der sed das wird ja auch journalistisch
gegen uns immer wieder verwandte in dem
dasteht nachfolgepartei von und so
obwohl wir heute eine ganz andere partei
sind das ist ein problem das andere
problem ist den fehler hat kommt in
dieser form nicht gemacht dass wir eben
den eindruck erwecken teilweise wir
werden für eine verstärkte zuwanderung
und das ist natürlich in einer situation
in der der sozialstaat abgebaut wurde
ist das eben von den kaum zu verstehen
die eben von sozialabbau betroffen sind
die alternative ist die traditionelle
spd politik also anstatt milliarden hier
auszugeben sie auszugeben für die
verbesserung der lebensumstände in den
lagern und in den hungergebieten aber
ich muss mir einräumen es gelingt mir
nicht teile meiner partei davon zu
überzeugen
dass man mit 100 euro etwa in der
sahel-zone viel mehr bewirken kann als
mit 100 euro her
ja wenn sie das schon anmerken dann wird
würde ich das gerne ein bisschen
vertiefen ich habe da ja mehrere zitate
von ihnen gefunden ich begreife 2 1 raus
schlüssel für den rechtsruck der
einkommensschwachen ist die verfehlte
flüchtlingspolitik dann frei ist immer
was wäre denn eine richtige
flüchtlingspolitik ein richtiger
flüchtlingspolitik wäre und das ist auch
das ergebnis der migrationsforschung es
gibt ja viele bücher die erschienen sind
dort zu helfen wo die hilfe am
wirkungsvollsten ist also etwa jetzt was
den vorderen orient angeht in den lagern
dort und da zeigt sich auch die der
fehler der deutschen flüchtlingspolitik
die haben das ja mit gemacht dass man
die ration von einem dollar am tag auf
einen halben runtergesetzt hat das war
kein geld mehr da und die millionen
haben sich gefragt was machen wir jetzt
und sie brachen dann unter anderem auch
nach deutschland
auf jeden fall sagte migrationsforschung
dort könnte man auch im sinne der
integration am besten helfen wenn man
dort den flüchtlingen die möglichkeit
geben könnte ein selbstbestimmtes leben
wieder aufzubauen
hier kennen wir die probleme alle und
die probleme sind ja wie man sieht nicht
gelöst weil viele voraussetzungen nicht
daran es fehlten diese billigen sozialen
wohnungen es fehlen auch die
arbeitsplätze integration kommt nicht
voran
selbst der bund hat der kaum flüchtling
beschäftigt das ist ja beschämend was da
geschehen ist also ich glaube es sind 27
oder so die beim bund beschäftigt sind
da sieht man dass auch die kanzlerin
ungeeignet war dieses problem anzugehen
weil sie überhaupt keine vorstellung hat
wie das problem zu lösen wäre aber
entscheidend ist man kann eben nur in
begrenztem umfang helfen auch das ist
schwer ebene durchzusetzen bestimmten
diskussionen also die leute davon zu
überzeugen alle wollen gern unbegrenzt
helfen geht aber nicht also muss man
sich entscheiden ich sage dort helfen wo
die hilfe am wirkungsvollsten ist also
ich sage ich jetzt hier leute nebenleute
sehr aufwändig unterbringe und bewirtete
helfe ich ihnen hunger gebeten und dort
wo die krankenzimmer das hat sie
überzeugt
linke politik überhaupt da wird ihnen
zunächst mal niemand widersprechen wenn
man sagt man muss vor ort helfen wo die
debatte darüber sehr heftig darüber geht
ob man begrenzen muss wie chinin nach
deutschland kommen ganz konkret ob es
eine obergrenze geben sollen was ist der
vorsitzende
da gibt es da wird ja alles immer
durcheinander geworfen darunter leidet
die ganze diskussion bei asyl sagen wir
sehr verständlich asylrecht muss gelten
dass heißt da gibt es keine obergrenze
so aber es kommt natürlich dazu das
natürlich nicht nur deutschland allein
die verpflichtung hat eben leute die
politisch verfolgt sind aufzunehmen
das zweite ist bürgerkriegsflüchtlingen
wenn die kommen von den bomben fliehen
dann sagt auch keiner gesetze genfer
konvention außer kraft aber die setzt er
genauso voraus dass alle beteiligten
länder hilfe anbieten
das problem ist die sogenannte armut
wanderung und da ist meine antwort die
man soll eben vor ort helfen wenn man
dort am meisten hilft jetzt gibt es ja
nicht wenige die ihm vorwerfen in der
flüchtlingsfrage ist die position von
oskar lafontaine ihre frau sahra
wagenknecht hat eine ähnliche position
nicht weit von der der erste ja das ist
ein dummer vorwurf weil die position was
mich angeht die verharrt vertrete ich
schon seit jahrzehnten kann nicht sagen
da kannten noch kein mensch die afd
die afc ist das ist ja deshalb nur groß
geworden weil die sogenannten
etablierten parteien so taten als wäre
das alles kein problem und alle probleme
haben anfangen schlicht ignorierten ich
will ein weiteres nebenwohnung und
arbeitsplätzen nennen das sind die
schulen und da sieht man ein echtes
problem etwa vor ort wenn man das sich
ansieht in den sogenannten in den
gebieten wo die leute wurden die nicht
viel geld haben
da treffen sie auf klassen wo also über
die hälfte kinder sind mit
migrationshintergrund und wo die lehrer
sagen wir kommen nicht mehr zurecht wir
brauchen zusätzliche kolleginnen
kollegen sind aber nicht da und dort wo
eben dann die sogenannten akademischen
urbanen schichten sehen die gebildeten
schichten ja dann taucht das problem
nicht auf und da sieht man dass diese
leute die fähigkeit verloren haben sich
in die lage der juden zu versetzen den
es die eben nicht so viel geld haben ich
mal ganz einfach zu nehmen
ich versuche man zu verstehen was sie
sagen wir haben folgende situation 19
schwer
na ja ich versuche die dimension zu
erklären wir haben 1998 hat die linke in
deutschland 52 prozent der stimmen
geholt bei der wahl 2017 38 und zwar
alle drei linken parteien zusammen spd
linke und grüne nur 38 prozent wenn sie
sich richtig verstehe sagen sie einer
der schlüssel warum die linke insgesamt
in deutschland so viel verloren hat ist
dass die leute nicht mehr verstehen wie
die leute denken insbesondere in der
flüchtlingsfrage gut dann würde ich
gerne so die leute muss man
unterscheiden ich würde sagen also uns
beiden brennt das problem wahrscheinlich
nicht auf dem nägel und vielen die in
ähnlichen lebenssituationen sind wie wir
auch aber eben diejenigen für die wir
vorgeben uns einzusetzen den brands auf
den nägeln
und man darf deren situation nicht
einfach nichts mit eingebauten bei spd
und linke zu viel lehrer zu viel
soziologen zu wenig kontakt zur
bevölkerung ja früher haben wir gesagt
zu weniger arbeite aber das ist einfach
so das ist ganz offensichtlich wenn man
ihnen zuhört beim reden hat man den
eindruck ihnen ist jetzt ein allgemein
sie können sich nicht mehr in die lage
versetzen die es sage ich mal mit 800
900 euro oder so im monat auskommen
müssen uns würden sie nicht so reden wie
sie reden heißt das dass die linke
insgesamt bestimmte begriffe und themen
heimat deutschen kulturnation
fälschlicherweise der rechten überlassen
hat ich bleibe mal bei der nation da ist
es so dass viele also in deutschland ist
die diskussion ganz anders als in
anderen europäischen ländern weil die
deutschen mit nationen irgendwann dann
auch nationalsozialismus und hitler oder
was weiß ich assoziieren was natürlich
völliger blödsinn ist sie können das in
folge sehen
als der satz wir dürfen nicht zum
nationalstaat zurückfällt eine
diskussion der ist logisch leider der
völliger unfug dann selbst die
kommission sagt es müssen aufgaben zum
nationalstaat zurückgegeben werden das
ist diese berührungsangst vom
nationalstaat das entscheidende ist dass
im nationalstaat weitgehend identisch
ist mit dem sozialstaat
und wenn dann in der linken was heißt
linken also leute die sich
fälschlicherweise als links verstehen
erzählt wird der nationalstaat ist eine
der entschuldigen
der sozialstaat ist eine
nationalistische verehrung wir müssen
öffnen für die ganze welt
dann mag das also studenten zirkeln
diskutiert werden ohne dass jemand auf
streit aber die arbeiter am fließband
die sagen die da haben sie nicht mehr
alle also das wichtigste ist eben dass
wir erkennen dass der besitz oder die
sicherheit der menschen der sozialstaat
ist um den geht es und zurzeit ist der
sozialstaat auf nationalstaatlicher
ebene organisiert und die vorstellung es
wurde besser werden wenn herr junker den
sozialstaat verwaltet die ist also
denkenden menschen nicht so ohne weiters
vermittelt wie weit gehen sie denn da
mit ihrer kritik ist zum beispiel auch
die bewegungs und niederlassungsfreiheit
innerhalb der europäischen union falsch
also müsste man auch irgendwelche
maßnahmen ergreifen
das aus bulgarien und rumänien nicht so
viele menschen nach deutschland kamen
wir haben sich nach wir haben dieses
thema schon diskutiert als ich noch nie
eine regierungspartei spd war da ging es
ja eben um die zuwanderung etwa von
polen und so weiter
da gab es ja fristen jahre lange fristen
war wohl das problem gesehen hat und
jetzt beim drexhage bitter dass eine
große rolle in dem eben die gerade die
leute mit geringem einkommen gesagt
haben die zuwanderer sind unsere
konkurrenten um die arbeitsplätze
deshalb hat auch corbijn in dieser frage
gesagt er würde also jetzt nicht eben
die totale niederlassungsfreiheit
akzeptieren dass ganze geschieht was
wenig bekannt ist in deutschland
allerdings sage ich jetzt können wir das
thema in das ist zu spät das thema
wieder aufzurollen
aber deshalb sollten wir nicht eben die
position beziehen immer mehr immer mehr
immer mehr und aus der ganzen welt
es ist nämlich einmal die position von
katja kipping ein der oskar lafontaine
verrät alle prinzipien die der linken
heilig sind ja und ich habe den fair
zurückgespielt und gesagt link ist
grundprinzip ist dass man dort hilft wo
die not am größten ist und das ist den
hungergebieten in den armutsgebieten und
da werden die milliarden nicht
eingesetzt hier so sagt die
migrationsforschung etwa was syrien ein
kommt der mittelstand aus syrien und
dort werden eben die gelder eingesetzt
das ist für mich keine linke position
immer mit der einschränkung dass wir
natürlich verpflichtet sind
kriegsflüchtlinge aufzunehmen jetzt
richten wir mal den blick nach vorne sie
gemeinsam mit ihrer frau sahra
wagenknecht haben vorgeschlagen
wir brauchen angesichts der generellen
krise der linken eine linke
sammlungsbewegung in deutschland was
bitte ist dass das heißt wir haben
bisher versucht eine sogenannte rot rot
grüne koalition auf den weg zu bringen
um können sie also die die zahlen
addieren und das haben sie ja vorhin
getan das ist also auf absehbare zeit
wohl kaum möglich dazu kommt das wird zu
wenig beachtet dass die grünen und die
sozialdemokraten sich massiv verändert
haben die grünen die ich erlebt habe von
anfang an waren damals noch eine partei
die das wirtschaftssystem in frage
gestellt haben sie haben gesagt mit
diesem wirtschaftssystem können wir die
umwelt nicht bewahren das ist weg die
sozialdemokraten waren zu zeiten willy
brandt und auch zu zeiten meines
vorsitzes eine ganz andere partei ich
habe die programme hiermit formuliert
sie haben zum beispiel godesberger
programm das immer wieder erwähnt wird
haben sie gesagt krieg ist kein mittel
der politik davon sind sie weg sie haben
gesagt wir müssen die soziale stadt
aufbauen statt dessen hat die regierung
schröder den größten sozialabbau nach
dem kriege betrieben zitat faz nicht
mein vernichtendes urteil
und das müssen wir alles beachten
insofern brauchen wir eine erneuerung
und die kann mehrere formen annehmen es
war ganz bewusst die absicht von mir
beispielsweise keine form vorzugeben
weil das wäre anmaßend
ich hab's verwiesen auf corbijn der als
innerhalb einer partei geschafft
allerdings auch mit dem sammeln über
internet und so weiter von oder über die
sozialen medien von neuen mitgliedern
also großer erfolg und ich habe
verwiesen auf la france thomis meine
frau ist meine chance
der eben auch über eine plattform eine
neue bewegung aufgebaut hat ich habe
auch von wissen über probleme aber das
ist jetzt so nicht mehr funktioniert das
sieht man doch und was ist denn da der
sinn von politik der sinn von politik
ist ich sage es mal ganz einfach das
in unserem land die sozialen leistungen
besser sind die löhne besser sind und
die renten besser sind weil ganz einfach
gesagt wir müssen wir sagen haben wir
nichts erreicht
aber das muss ich überlegen muss ich
muss ich den herrn und wenn sie jetzt
sagen ich mache eine linke
sammlungsbewegung da verstehe ich doch
dass sie über das spektrum der
linkspartei hinaus greifen wollen aber
wenn sie jetzt immer nur das programm
der linkspartei hier sagen dann greifen
sie ja nicht über das programm der
linkspartei hinaus also sie müssen doch
auch dann teile der sozialdemokraten
teile der grünen zu sich ziehen so habe
ich das zumindest verstanden
dann müssen sie doch auch kompromisse
machen dann müssen sie doch im
extremfall sage ich auch wolfgang
clement und gerd schröder wieder auf
ihre seite müssen wir so gar nicht die
position die wir vertreten und das ist
ja das überraschend und geht ja wieder
zu ihre eingangsfrage zurück die
position was löhne renten
sozialleistungen an den wänden einer
großen mehrheit der bevölkerung geteilt
das interessante ist ja es gibt im
repräsentativen system bundestag keine
abbildung dieser mehrheit
wir haben ja und das steht er selbst im
armuts und reichtumsbericht der
bundesregierung da habe ich gelacht als
ich das gelesen habe ich da wir hatten
das denn rein geschrieben
wir haben eine situation dass nur die
gesetze eine chance haben in den oberen
zehntausend zu gute kommen die anderen
gesetze haben kaum eine chance er weiß
die jüngsten koalitionsverhandlungen
wenn sie sich mal heute angucken für
interessierte zuhörerinnen und zuhörer
jetzt was auf den nachdenkseiten ein
fachmann geschrieben hat zu der
grundrente die angebliche ein großer
erfolg ist da sehen sie dass sich
irgendwie soziale verbesserungen einfach
nicht mehr durchsetzen lassen unter
anderem auch weil das denken der
beteiligten so verformt ist über viele
jahre dass sie gar nicht mehr auf die
idee kommen
ich sag dann mich hat ein
sozialdemokratischer was sollen wir denn
machen ich habe gesagt schreibt das
rennen wie sie jetzt in österreich ab
das dürfte nicht so schwer sein und dann
hebt er die hand mehr müsst ihr nicht
machen und ihr habt sofort wieder einen
aufzug an wählerstimmen wirklich mehr
müssen sie nicht mehr sie haben ja ganz
bewusst nicht gesagt wir brauchen eine
linke sammlungspartei sie haben gesagt
sie wir brauchen eine linke
sammlungsbewegung heißt das
traditionelle parteien haben ausgedient
was wollen sie damit ausdrücken dass es
sagen bewegung statt
ganz bewusst wollte ich keine konkrete
form vorgeben und es ist ja auch zu
beobachten dass das traditionelle
parteien system in europa im umbruch ist
italien oder spanien und frankreich oder
so ich gucke wenn ich solche vorschläge
machen nicht nur auf deutschland sondern
schaue eben auf die anderen europäischen
ländern in denen ich mich etwas besser
auskenne so und da ist das im umbau
deswegen sage ich wir müssen einen
neuanfang versuchen und der kann auch
von land zu land verschieden sein wird
wir haben über coby gesprochen
vielleicht geht das in dieser form mit
dem handeln personal in deutschland
nicht ist ja ein problem der spd wer ist
dort kaum ihn ja so dann muss man eben
versuchen eine andere form zu finden
sind habe ich auf frankreich verwiesen
die spd ist aber noch nicht so weit wie
die partie sozialist die er dann
geschont des auf sieben prozent in der
größenordnung geht noch weiter nach der
ursache
aber da bei der spd um das zum zweiten
mal dazu sagen weil wir das so wichtig
ist was ich nicht verstehe ist dass man
auf die wähler nicht hören man kann ja
alle anderen sagen sie wissen nichts
aber die wähler die braucht man doch wer
unterstützt sie bei dieser linken
sammlungsbewegung außer sarah wandel
es gibt ja resonanzen dir also auch auf
die auf den sozialen medien
festzustellen sind da gibt es ja eine
beachtliche zustimmung also derjenigen
die sich melden das sind nicht einmal
100 das geht die tausende oder so die
also dann sein das ist eine sehr gute
idee wir werden angesprochen als ich
werde angesprochen würde ich an wo ich
mich aufhalte und leute mich ansprechen
auf diese bewegung die das problem ist
dass etwa in den führungsetagen der spd
oder in der grünen oder so das
klassische denken also der in der
etablierten partei vorherrscht und die
interessieren sich dafür haben sie
andrea nahles schon mal angerufen gesagt
wäre es nicht eine idee und andrea
nahles hat das ja sicherlich zu erkennen
ist genommen aber ich glaube der erste
schritt denn sie machen müsste wäre der
zu sagen das kann so nicht weitergehen
aber sie erweckt überhaupt nicht den
eindruck dass ihr selbst die 16 prozent
die jetzt da gemessen werden
denn die botschaft vermittelt haben du
musst dich ändern wenn sie
eine sammlung wenn sie sammeln wollen
eine sammlungsbewegung machen wollen
dann können sie doch nicht immer nur
sagen meine politik ist richtig und die
andere ist da müssen sie doch irgendwo
zeigen ich bin 18 kompromissfähig das
ist wieder was andere kompromiss weil
der komponist haben sie ja formuliert
auf die neoliberale politik mein
gegenargument war ja dass die mehrheit
der bevölkerung die position für richtig
reaktiviert für richtig halten
das können sie wieder zurück fragen
warum setzen sich nicht durch aber
entscheidend ist das ist ja gemessen
wenn sie sagen wollen sie also die
rennen form von österreicher wollen sie
jetzt ist er stört daran formel machen
sich gar nicht so frage ich sie kriegen
die antworten so wir sind dabei im
anfang jetzt wir haben die diskussion in
gang gesetzt und ich bin froh darüber
dass sie in der sendung sage das ohne
also einfach weil es so ist dass sie
darauf zurückkommen
der spiegel hat ein titel darüber
gemacht die zeit das thema aufgegriffen
das muss ja in gang kommen das ist jetzt
in gang
und sie können davon ausgehen dass ich
selbstverständlich mit meinen
möglichkeiten gespräche führe nur das
ganze muss ja irgendwann dann zu einem
ergebnis gebracht werden und es war ja
auch schwer das in der eigenen partei
zum vermittler am anfang haben die
sofort wieder gedacht alle ihre was weiß
ich besitzt wir stehen in frage jetzt
hat sich diese missionen etwas entspannt
jetzt gibt es auch andere führende
politiker die von sammlungsbewegung der
sprechen
insofern muss das jetzt einfach weiter
angetrieben werden da soll ich meine
hand wollen solche bewegungen waren in
letzter zeit verarmten erfolgreich wenn
es eine charismatische person an der
spitze gab das ist bei podemos so das
ist in frankreich bei makro der fall das
ist in österreich auf der anderen seite
des politischen spektrums bei kurz der
fall
wer könnte diese personen auf der linken
seite ich mache ja auch gleich mal ein
vorschlag wie nennen das ganze team
sarah oder lister sahra wagenknecht ein
vorschlag der insoweit begründet ist als
meine frau eben ziemlich hohe
zustimmungswerte hat zumindest im
bereich des linken spektrums aber wir
haben von anfang gesagt es wäre
natürlich völlig
dumm jetzt zu sagen also wir haben jetzt
eine bewegung bewegung wo an der spitze
diejenige steht die das mitträgt nein
wir sind der auffassung da müssen
mehrere zusammenkommen die ebenheit sind
das mitzutragen
und dann muss man sich darüber
unterhalten wie man das ganze
organisiert es gibt immer zwei dinge
einmal die inhalte zum anderen haben sie
völlig recht auch das führungspersonal
das ist in den linken parteien immer
schwer zu vermitteln
aber das war ja auch so als für die
linke gegründet haben
wenn damals eben auf der seite der
ehemaligen pds ein bisky und gysi mich
bereit gewesen wären so sagen wir sind
interessiert daran
und wenn ich damals als ehemals
spd-vorsitzender nicht gesagt hätte ich
mache dazu bedingungen meine kandidatur
wird überhaupt nichts zustande gekommen
insofern ist das ist inhaltlich und
inhaltliche fragen müssen stimmen und
die personen müssen sich finden
wie arbeiten sie und ihre frau den
zusammen entwickeln sie solche konzepte
zb die linke sammlungsbewegung zusammen
gemeinsam
wir sitzen wie wir jetzt zusammensetzen
dann früchte würden reden auch über
politik selbstverständlich war dass er
eben unser leben ist die politik aber
dann kommen in welcher ergebnis das ist
klar nur die idee dass es so nicht
weitergehen kann das ist ja jetzt auch
der erfolg dieser diskussion das ist
hier keine idee die nach uns kommen
das sind eine ganze reihe von leuten die
jetzt sagen 'ja ja ihr habt recht wir
können hier nicht da somit so um 30
prozent potenzial jetzt versuchen
irgendetwas zu ändern
mich würde mal interessieren sie waren
ihr ganzes leben ja ein politisches
alphatier
wie schwer fällt es ihnen denn jetzt das
ganze aus der zuschauerperspektive aus
saarbrücken zu betrachten
zunächst ist es ja schwierig wenn man
eben das habe ich erlebt zurückgetreten
bin als finanzminister also von dieser
ebene jetzt sich völlig zurückzieht das
ist ein umstellungsprozess der auch
sammer kraft abverlangt das zu
bewältigen oder so
und da war das durchaus habe ich eine
zeitlang gebraucht um mich dann neu zu
orientieren und neu einzustellen
als ich dann krankheitsbedingt auch mich
von der bundesebene der linken
zurückgezogen habe da war das weniger
problematisch und wollen immer gesagt er
hätte das zitieren das leben hat mir
zwei warnschüsse erteilt einmal bei dem
attentat messerattentat 1990 und an die
krebserkrankung 2009 war so und heute
wie gesagt sehe ich da kein großes
problem manchmal sondern ich hab ja
nicht mehr den ehrgeiz das sind keine
bücher auf freie äußern als andere
irgendwelche karrieren zu machen oder
irgendetwas für meinen für mein ego zu
tun sondern ich kann mich äußern und was
eben bleibt das haben sie auch
angesprochen ist das politische
engagement da habe ich gesagt hab ich im
krücken laufen oder so politisch
engagiert weil ich immer noch sein
es ist ja immer schwierig wenn man eine
ein ehepaar ist beide haben eine
wichtige rolle in dieser partei erhalten
sie sich auch bewusst etwas zurück um
die karriere ihrer frau in der linken
nicht nicht zu gefährden weil sowas
gibts ja immer leute die sagen der oscar
der zieht wie er seine frau immer noch
gestritten ja dass wir haben sehr viele
angebote in talkshows gemeinsam
aufzudrücken gemeinsam bücher zu
schreiben aufsetzen zu sagen das machen
wir bewusst nicht wir wollen ja gerade
nicht dass diese tour gemacht wird dsm
pärchen das hat diese zeit dieselben
show oder ich selber nummer habe und da
gibt gab es ja dann auch versuche eben
entweder mir zu unterstellen ich sei
also was will ich der hanswurst meiner
frau oder umgekehrt
meine frau würde von mir gesteuert da
müssen wir gegen also gegen halt das tun
wir auch aber wir können natürlich nicht
ganz weg drücken weil das ist nun mal so
es ist nicht so leicht und dass wir
verheiratet sind es ist so wenn sich
stolz auf ihre fragen ja
selbstverständlich
sonst wäre ich wahrscheinlich gar nicht
zusammen
wie viel mut wussten sie eigentlich
aufbringen noch mal zu heiraten nach
immerhin drei scheidungen gut aus weiß
noch mal dafür mut aufbringen muss dass
man es ist es ist nicht die konvention
lange zeit gewesen insbesondere bei der
jugend nicht heute ist das ja ganz
anders
und heute gibt es ja auch ein argument
dass es besser ist eben neue
partnerschaften dann auch offiziell
einzugehen als ständig fremdzugehen also
dass wir ja nun ein weiteres thema die
größten fremdgehenden nationen stellen
sich dann vor die kamera und sagen ich
bin doch eine lichtgestalt was meine
lieben angehen könnte nahmen den tisch
aber nicht was macht das ehepaar wagen
nicht lafontaine wenn sie mal nicht ihre
politiker ja wir haben ja viele
gemeinsamkeiten das glaube ich ist auch
wichtig brecht hat sich mal so geäußert
wir haben beide fahren wir gerne fahrrad
machen gefordert wurden ich habe mal
gehört am anfang haben sie nie gebraucht
um mit ihrer frauen mitzuhalten stimmt
das ist jetzt immer noch den beiden muss
ich jetzt nicht mehr ich hab's geschafft
so weit mich fit zu machen dass ich
damit kommen wir machen ja auch lange
strecken verfahren 100 kilometer schon
ohne also anzugeben das waren wir ohne
probleme aber wir haben gehen auch gerne
pilze sammeln um ein anderes hobby zu
nennen die pilze zeit kommt jetzt bald
wieder eine pilze kenne wissen dass
jetzt bald die morcheln kann
beispielsweise die literatur also
außerhalb des politischen interessiert
uns also wir haben genug gemeinsamkeiten
außerhalb des politischen denn wenn wir
nur über politik wünschen würden dass
wir vielleicht auch etwas einseitig hat
haben sich bei ihnen persönlich auch die
prioritäten ein bisschen verschoben also
diese die politik nicht mehr ganz so
alleine da stehen dafür auch ein
bisschen schön das leben frankreich
essen also eigentlich war ich immer so
ein doppel wesen auf der einen seite
hoch engagiert politisch auch schon in
jüngeren jahren auf der anderen seite
hatte ich immer die sehnsucht ein
anderes leben zu leben aus dieser
situation bin ich eigentlich nie
rausgekommen nur heute habe ich es
leichter das andere leben auch zu leben
wenn sie zurückblicken auf ihr
politisches leben sind sie zufrieden mit
dem was sie erreicht haben oder haben
das gefühl das ist am ende immer alles
dann doch unvollendet geblieben ja und
nein ja weil ich natürlich
sie kennen ja auch saarbrücken ich
brauche hier nur durch die stadt zu
gehen da sehe ich vieles was eben zu
meiner zeit als oberbürgermeister
angestoßen und realisiert wurde und
dadurch das land da kann ich auch vieles
erzählen das waren ja eine lange zeit
und auf bundesebene ist die bilanz sehr
gemischt auf der einen seite gab es eben
zu beginn etwa auch der der
rot-rot-grünen koalition eine reihe von
entscheidungen die bis zum heutigen tag
halten ist da manchmal noch
facharbeitern wisst ihr eigentlich dass
die steuerfreiheit der nacht und
schichtzuschläge beispielsweise durch
gekämpft worden ist denn der die
regierung kohl wollte das ja alles
abschaffen also die steueroasen des
kleinen mannes auf der anderen seite bin
ich natürlich enttäuscht dass der kampf
um mehr soziale gerechtigkeit umgehen
geht ja dass der also in den letzten
jahren auf der verliererstraße war das
ist einfach so darüber kann man sich
nichts im weg täuschen aber ich bin nie
in die politik gegangen in dem
bewusstsein
es wird alles glattgehen du wirst also
nur auf der erfolgsstraße bewegen
braucht ja nur biografien und welche
leute zu lesen dann weiß man das leben
ist ein auf und ab das war der dialog
heute mit oskar lafontaine herzlichen
dank dass es gespräche und in liebe zu
scheuen liebe zuschauer schön habt
[Musik]
[Applaus]